hello everybody and welcome to the 19th
part of our Python tkinter programming
tutorial video we're actually building a
full-sized application so where we left
office we were basically adding all the
menu items kind of creating the backend
structure to how those will work some of
them are actually doing what their
actual job is some of them still need
some building up to actually realize
what has been done but yes so so now
we're gonna add the last thing which is
the tutorial option we're just gonna
kind of show when you go to help
tutorial we're not gonna actually write
this tutorial because the program isn't
complete yet so there's not much point
to write a full tutorial when that might
not be the best tutorial for the end
result but anyway we're gonna actually
we're just gonna show like how like we
might do a tutorial so let's go ahead
and get started so we're gonna -
according to find tutorial let me just
cut that and we'll put that up here so
tutorial no longer will pass we've got a
couple of things we are going to go
ahead and define page two as so I think
on this I'm trying to think here maybe
okay because we're gonna start Tut so I
didn't really quite think this through
cuz this one am I in my actual code I
use that leave mini well we'll change
that maybe at the very end so for now
we'll say leave mini what and then what
die
destroy okay so then define page two
will be leave mini so in theory I think
what I could do is just like Tut dot
destroy and then we could do tattoo
right equals TK capital t k and in fact
let me just comment this out we might
not need that after all so the you know
the load up tutorial of a load of window
and then they'll progress into page two
which will redefine itself
TK dot c k and then we'll do define page
three like this and then again we'll do
cut to dot
destroy and basically you would continue
doing this all the way to as deep as you
wanted it to go but for now we'll just
go to three pages and this will
basically force a specific succession
you might not want a specific succession
you might actually want your tutorial to
have like a navigation bar to it and
people can pick the various options I've
always been a huge fan of like clicking
on a tutorial and having them walk me
through the application one step at a
time
and that'd be it I've always found this
to be the most beneficial to me you
might change your mind and if you do
feel free to write your own little
tutorial that you think is superior and
if it's good enough share the code with
me and we'll let the user decide if they
want to walk through or more of a
navigation you know you can always have
two tutorials so page three taught to
destroy and then we define tutorial 3 so
Tut three for example when you pull TK
TK and basically what happens is around
so like we haven't actually defined the
tutorial page yet and we will it will be
like down he point to the screen you
can't see the screen it'll be down here
and then page twos definition will have
page three and whenever we're ready for
page three and because like basically
what happens we'll have page two code
here and then the button that you click
next the command for next will be page
three which destroys page two loads up
page three with the whatever data is in
page 3 that's how it works so what we'll
do is we'll put some code here now so
Tut three equals TK TK tight three WM
underscore title we'll call the
part three and I will say label equals t
TK dot capital label Tut three texts
will equal part 3 and then the font that
we use we're going to use just the norm
underscore want like that good enough
and then we're going to do label dot
pack as usual with our labels we do side
top fill X and Patty ten why not one
ninety ten then we're gonna be one
equals TCK dot button with a capital b
that button goes to two to three text is
since this is the last one we're gonna
say the text is done and then the
command itself will just be touch 3 dot
destroy easy enough
then we're gonna do B whoops be one dot
pack and then cut three main loop okay
so that's page three but now we have to
define page two right so this is what
will run when the user clicks the same
kind of structured button is here and
it'll run Tut instead of drawing top
three destroy Iran's page three which
just so happens to be the first thing
that page three does is destroy page two
and then it runs page three
so now after now that we've defined page
three we needed to find page two and
page 2 will basically be exactly the
same as page three so I'm gonna go ahead
and just copy this and then put here
paste and highlight this section hold
control Open bracket section shift it
over if that doesn't work for you sorry
and now instead of Tut three this is
tattoo it's not part three it's part two
it's not Tut three it's two it's part
two ah not done next and then not Tut
three dot destroy it's actually Tut
actually no it's not even any destroy it
would be the command is page three
age three packs and then not cut too
many loop to it I mean not tuck three
let me loop that to main loop okay now
we define the main tutorial and so so
for example we'll just will write this
one ourselves so let's say Tut and then
that equals TK TK and then Tut WM
underscore title tittle equals tutorial
and then we're gonna have label equals C
D K dot label and that's going to be two
Tut texts will be what do you need help
with and the font will be norm
underscore all caps font
okay now label dot pack as usual or
patch always the same so let's go ahead
and just copy this right here I'm not
gonna write that again paste good and
now it's where we're gonna put in some
buttons so and this is what I was
talking about before you don't actually
have to have a walk through necessarily
like the user might just have a simple
question so like for example we could
have a b1 equals TDK dot button that
button goes to Tut and the text of that
button equals overview of the
application so this is the one it's
gonna walk them through step by step in
a very linear progression methodology
that is what we basically coded up in
this window here that I'm pointing to
that you can't see uh-huh
I'll review the application and then
command if they do that would be page -
okay and that's this function which
immediately destroys the tutorial starts
up a new window loads up page three just
in case we call it and then runs page
two and you know in theory gives it
tutorial so or the second part of our
tutorial so that's for button one then
we'll just say B 1 dot pack easy enough
so we don't have to type everything all
again let's just copy that
I'll actually tends to be empty
parameters there so cop
this and then pasted twice paste paste
now we're going to talk about B 2 B 2
and this will be B 3 3 so 4 B 2 what do
we want button 2 to do well button 2
maybe the user wants just to know how to
trade so how do I trade with this
clients okay
the command here we're gonna say for now
is just lambda : pop-up message not yet
completed and then this other one will
be the same thing with the command not
yet completed so copy that paste so
they're both you know commands not yet
completed and then so someone might ask
how do i tribute this client and then
someone else might ask a popular
question that people want to know is is
with indicator questions help you know
how to indicators work that sort of
thing another one is how do I get an API
you know how do i acquire API
information because to trade on the
various exchanges you have to connect to
the API on that exchange so people might
ask that question and then finally when
everything's all said and done however
we're gonna do Tut's dots main loop
empty parms and that's that that is our
tutorial function so now well you can
save and run that hopefully without
error we'll see now we have help
tutorial they click on a tutorial this
little window comes up what do you need
help with
they might click how do i trade with
this client that's not yet completed
that's not yet completed overview the
application however they click that a
new window pops up part two we didn't
pack the button good job okay one second
let's go pack that button
well actually we got a trace back ah
let's see if I can figure it out before
we get there but I'm not seeing it oh
here it is here's our trace back right
here figured it out guys so we packed
that's the reason the button didn't even
show up either the button was packed to
Tut's 3 or we do Tut too but we still
might su [ __ ] figure out if we have
another trace back somewhere I'm not
seeing why we would or another
huh I'm gonna trace back anyway we'll
have to watch for trace back help
tutorial overview part 2 next part 3
awesome done okay that worked no errors
besides the syntax that counter nonsense
awesome so but this warning is up here
by the way is that we have this these
default values there's a couple of
things that we could do till I get away
from this but we're just gonna leave
them there for now it's not like a it's
not a world stopping error as you can
see the application still runs it's
really just more of a syntactical
problem the GUI dough would be very
unhappy with me so anyways the tutorial
is done now I mean it's not this the
back end so this would be simple
questions that people might have this
would be like a walkthrough tutorial so
they click on that now they're learning
about one part there it says you know
click on top indicator add RS I click 14
awesome you've added a top indicator
okay so that's part two then they hit
next because they're done now you can
add bottom indicators click on bottom
indicator back to it and so on okay so
you can do that all the way through
really walk the client through how the
walk the client how the client works
anyway so that's that so now we've got
all of the menu options that I initially
want us to cover and now we need to
start building those menu options so a
lot of them are fairly easy but we're
well some of them are fairly easy the
rest of most of these are gonna require
some pretty fancy code and at this point
this is where this program is going to
heavily veer off into weighing more so
into the actual purpose of this client
so up at at this point we've really
built a backbone that really could be
supported by a huge array of clients but
now we're actually going to be really
building this client out for this very
specific purpose of working with Bitcoin
trading and all of that the main thing
that I would say is still pertinent to
anybody else is what we'll end up doing
with trading especially manual trading
what manual trading is going to do is
it's going to open up another window so
it'll be
another window but it's still part of
the application itself so you'll have
two windows mostly because people may
want to put you know they're trading
window over here the main graph window
over here you should let them kind of
orient where everything is so and that
was actually something that people kind
of voted on on reddit so that's the way
we're going to do it
so anyways so that's that that's what
you guys have to look forward to we're
going to start working on getting this
graph to connect or this client to
connect to see of BTC for the daily data
then working on the open high low close
actually adding the indicators that kind
of stuff and then after that trading
that kind of stuff also pause/resume
doesn't actually work at the moment
anyway that kind of stuff so we're
really gonna actually start pulling this
application together and making
something interesting out of it now so
anyway he's got a nice back end
hopefully you guys are enjoying I was
really enjoyed doing this really this
series and actually working on this
application I didn't really know if if
you could do something like this in
Python successfully so I'm pretty
confident we can the major hurdle I
think now in the future is actually
threading this application but I know
with 100 cent certainty it's possible I
just have not done it so that'll be a
hurdle anyway if you guys have any
questions or comments please feel free
to leave them below otherwise you know
the deal as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support subscriptions
and actually thank you for donations as
well I have received I've started
receiving donations someone actually
mailed me a check the other day for this
specific series so thank you so much for
those so anyways um stay tuned the next
video as always thanks for watching
these rows for subscriptions